j'ai condamné de toutes mes forces
l'attentât qui a eu lieu dans charlie
hebdo
les journalistes qui sont morts et c'est
intolérable de mourir pour des idées ou
pour un message qu'ont souhaité
recentrer ça on est tous d'accord
cependant hyper cacher moi je suis bien
évidemment il perd cacher mais je peux
pas être charlie pour d'autres raisons
et vous comprendrez la différence et la
nuance ce ne veut pas dire que ceux qui
sont morts à charlie hebdo l'ont mérité
je n'ai jamais dit ça il ne le dirai
jamais ça monsieur geoffrey rien la
qualification merci beaucoup merci merci
gaspari moi j'ai la première chose que
j'ai envie de dire c'est que quand j'ai
quand j'ai découvert ça j'ai été en
réalité choqué par le courage de la
rédaction de charlie hebdo comme eric
naulleau ce que je me suis dit ils sont
hallucinants cinq ans après de deux
doses et de le faire de l'assumer de
l'assumer comme ils l'ont fait dans les
textes qu'ils ont publiées je reconnais
que c'est un courage qui pourraient moi
me manquer si j'étais confronté à la
même chose parce qu'en réalité ils ont
vraiment peur de rien ensuite je trouve
le débat passionnant est en fait
beaucoup de choses sont dites et
beaucoup de choses sont vraies mais à la
fin il faut tirer des conclusions hyper
claire jeu on peut être choqué par les
pilotes chef de charlie hebdo c'est le
cas de beaucoup de gens moi je mets
plein de personnalités politiques qui me
disent ouais mais moi j'ai déjà été
caricaturé c'est une catastrophe
récemment nadine morano par exemple
guillaume j'ai été caricaturé en
trisomique c'est horrible etc
mais en fait à la fin si vous parliez
tout à l'heure de vivans de vivre
ensemble si le vivre ensemble existe
vraiment on doit accepter de vivre dans
un pays où on peut être caricaturées où
on peut être attaqué ou ça peut être
ultra violent et que ça reste dans le
cadre du débat public avec ça ne vient
pas c'est le pays des bisounours que tu
es pas le payer des billets
d'enregistrement parce que ton argument
était très intéressant tout à l'heure
oui la sécurité c'est très important et
il allait la sécurité on en rêve tous on
rêverait que cela n'existe pas mais ce
que tu demandes en creux et honnêtement
je comprends tu viens du milieu de la
sécurité c'est ton travail c'est son
métier
est ce que tu te montres incrustées
d'abdiquer une liberté pour la sécurité
une liberté fondamentale qui est celle
de pouvoir choquer de pouvoir quatre
caricatures et qui dans un pays est en
effet c'était un peu bisounours mais qui
dans un pays civilisé avec une une
volonté de vivre ensemble mais pour de
vrai en fait devrait s'exprimer
normalement et là aujourd'hui en fait on
en mer
voir arbitrer ce choix entre liberté et
sécurité moi je suis désolé je trouve
que c'est une régression ils n'ont rien
fait englos à l'époque ouais juste moi
moi je vous fais le relais un petit peu
de ce que je vois passer et de ce que
j'entends mois voilà je vous dis ils ont
fait leur travail
charlie hebdo mois pour moi on peut
juste leur reprocher de ne pas être
drôle
sachant ce que tout le monde en convient
ils sont plus drôles depuis des années
bon après charlie hebdo il ya plein de
gens qui disent on sort d'une crise
sanitaire et non on va traverser une
crise économique sans précédent
on a un sentiment d'insécurité en france
comme jamais est ce que c'est le moment
d'aller rajouter comme on dit de l'huile
sur le feu est ce que c'est le moment de
faire ce genre de caricatures est-ce que
je pense que c'est un petit peu ce que
veut exprimer aussi bruno béthouart
complètement est ce que c'est le moment
est-ce que c'est pas rajouter encore des
difficultés et quand je vois le public
qui dit oui nous on peut être victime de
ce genre de provocation même s'ils font
que leur travail
qu'est-ce qu'on répond à ces gens là je
vois on leur dit quoi l'arrivée victime
aussi de la politique étrangère de la
france qui va pas plaire à tel ou tel
groupe donc on demande quoi au
gouvernement français d'arrêter sa
politique étrangère c'est parce que ça
peut provoquer on parle de terrorisme
non mais c'est c'est sans fin ne plus
rien faire sous prétexte que cela se
fait le relais de ce que j'ai demandé
les raisons et parce que l'esprit
charlie est plutôt en recul joue bien
sûr il aurait menacé et il est très très
fort et pourtant annoncée d'autant qu'en
courageux de l'entente c'est vrai qu'il
n'était pas très fort mais les avions
n'avaient même pas d'esprit charlie
charlie plus personne ne lisait chalet
la salle richard lowden planis
l'anecdote qu'elle quelques mois avant
les attentats de 2015 françois hollande
avait reçu dans son bureau
charb tignes huska but bernard maryse
toute la rédac on fait lui aussi
pourquoi il est allé voir françois
hollande est allé voir françois hollande
pour lui dire que le journal et mettre
la clé sous la porte que c'était fini en
fait avec c'est ce que plus personne ne
lisait le journal que plus personne ne
l'achetez je sais pas c'est parce que il
était à côté de l'époque pas de rolex
avant tout cas le plus personne ne
naulleau lisez pas ce qu'on fait c'est
dit et dans l'indifférence et pourtant
les dessins étaient toujours aussi
violents etc
et je pense que les gens n'étaient pas
charlie le sont redevenus à un moment
donné parce que je pense que quelque
chose de fondamental a été touché dans
notre pays en réalité d'un coup d'un
seul à je rejoins eric naulleau la
liberté d'expression c'est pas une
valeur parmi d'autres dans notre pays
c'est une valeur cardinale et centrale
et puis évidemment ça a touché les gens
qu'on connaissait dans l'âme à risque a
bien sûr eu à répétition de grand talent